welcome to everybody watching
from your office or your home to the
spectators alternative conference
this session the green revolution how
technological advancements can level up
written sustainably is kindly sponsored
by drax the uk of course was the first
major economy to set a net zero carbon
emission target
but our work is certainly cut out for us
23 million homes are fueled by natural
gas and will need upgrading while nearly
90 percent of vehicles
on uk roads are still powered by petrol
and diesel so reaching that zero is
going to require big changes on our part
but we'll also need to sustain our
standards of living and our quality of
life indeed
life needs to get better not worse under
the new guidance or rules or changes
that come into play
and as we make this transition we also
of course
can never forget that we are recovering
from
severe economic damage caused by the
coven 19 pandemic
which has been afflict inflicted upon
the whole world and we have an
opportunity in the uk
to potentially merge the leveling up
agenda with green solutions
and the coveted recovery the government
has yet to establish a clear path as to
how it will achieve
net zero by 2050 but we know that new
technology
potentially greenhouse gas removal
technologies along with others
will need to play a role in leading the
charge to carbon neutrality
so to discuss what is not a small topic
we've brought together a fantastic panel
will gardeners the group chief executive
officer for drax
andrew griffith is the conservative mp
and former business advisor to the prime
minister
dr jonathan marshall is head of analysis
at energy and climate intelligence
and emma pinchbeck is chief executive of
energy uk
fantastic panel thrilled to have you
thanks for joining me
um i'm going to start by asking each of
our panelists to speak for two or three
minutes tops just to give a few opening
remarks
so we can dive right into questions and
conversation and of course the most
important part is for you the audience
to have your say as well so please
submit your questions
into the little questions box on
spectator tv
those will be funneled through to me and
i'll put your questions to our panel
um so dr jonathan marshall i'm going to
start with you
great thank you so the overlaps between
the government's leveling up agenda and
its net zero target have been around for
a long time but now there's clear
potential for tailored economic
interventions to link the two
as the government looks to reboot the
economy there's also strong correlation
between regions suffering most from kobe
19 economically and in terms of current
infection rates and those that can be
boosted by delivering on plans to build
that better
so there's three parts of the economy
that are focused on recent eciu report
i'm
going to gloss over the top of the first
of which in terms of the best banker
book
in um in terms of jobs creates that our
mission has tackled is
upgrading britain's homes the millions
and millions of properties below the
government's intended
efficiency target and they're spread all
around the country with the leakest
often
in areas hardest hit by the pandemic
cutting energy away from our homes will
make the next step in cleaning up heat
whether through heat pumps or hydrogen
easier
as well as boosting millions of trade
peoples and small businesses
the green homes grant announced in the
summer statement was a start here but
it's not really going to make a dent
without turning out into a long-term
action
second is renewable energy um it's
already revitalizing
coastal communities there's turbine
factories ports maintenance jobs spread
all around
especially the east coast of england and
scotland and the offshore insect is
booming as well and set to deliver ever
lower costs as technology presses ahead
uk is also poised to make the most of
floating offshore wind technology with a
huge global market as it can be deployed
in
seas that are too deep for current um
current technologies
there's also a big potential for onshore
wind solar both in terms of new capacity
and
upgrading our oldest wind and solar
farms they come to the end of their
lives in fact the government own
renewable energy planning database
shares more than 700 projects awaiting
construction again all around the
country
tied in with the power sector is
readying a high performance electric
vehicle charging network
um we've already seen the rumors that
the phase update for sales of petrol and
diesel cars could be brought forward to
2030
and this had been shown to support tens
of thousands of permanent jobs
installing and maintaining charging
points again spread all over the country
the appeal of electric vehicles are
clear and it really shouldn't be held
back by insufficient infrastructure
until last week all eyes were on the
budget and the comprehensive spending
review to the outline in the next stages
of the green recovery
while the delay to these and the sort of
downgrading of the csr to a one-year
intervention rather than a longer one um
it obviously gives more time to end the
detail the still scope ash in the short
term
before the end of this year the
government is expected to release the
energy white paper a building
decarbonization strategy a transport
decarbonization strategy and a national
infrastructure strategy
making the right calls in all of these
can help to get the uk's green recovery
up and running
thanks so much jonathan i'm going to
turn to will gardner
group chief executive officer for drax
thank you kate and i want to just maybe
i'll pick up on
one point that johnny made which is
about how renewable energy can be a big
driver of this both green recovery um a
bounce back from covet 19 and
enable the uk to be a world leader in
some of the next generation
technologies that are coming down the
pipe i think as the prime minister
mentioned last week
he's become an advocate or an evangelist
i think is the word he used
for carbon capture and storage uh and i
want to sort of give a few of the
details around how i think that can help
right
so around the uk different industrial
clusters are have been formed
to actually work with the government to
put in place the infrastructure of
carbon capture and storage
and the idea here is that if we capture
co2 coming from
mostly industry but also i'll come back
to
power generation is second we can
effectively enable
you know parts of the uk a lot of them
in the north um to effectively
maintain their industrial infrastructure
their jobs with what they have in place
and sort of allow those to be
competitive
as we move into a net zero in green
economy so give an example of where
draxes we are in the humber
humber side has you know you know
significant
heavy industry um there are as many as
fifty five thousand
heavy jobs and jobs now there and every
industry that we think could be saved or
continue
in a net zero world if we put the carbon
capture and storage
infrastructure in place to actually
capture the co2 coming out of those
industries and store it under the north
sea
how can drax contribute to this or what
is sort of the special piece that we
have because
again you mentioned at the beginning the
opportunity or the need
ultimately for negative emissions
technologies if we're going to hit net
zero
not only are we going to have to find
ways of offsetting some emissions that
might
be very difficult ultimately to to
effectively get to zero
but actually i think we need to start
thinking of negative emissions as a way
to decarbonize faster
ultimately less expensively or cheaper
and ultimately with
less restaurants so drax power station
is converted from being
probably the largest single source of
emissions in the uk to being
the largest decarbonization project in
western europe by using sustainable
biomass if we add carbon capture and
storage infrastructure to the power
station we can ultimately be
carbon negative meaning that we'll be
taking more co2 out of the atmosphere
than we're actually
putting into it right and if we do that
ultimately we think we can do that at a
cost of let's say less than
100 pounds a ton of co2 which is
significantly less expensive than a lot
of the other things that
still need to be decarbonized and
ultimately we think that's a great way
for
again the leveling up to continue we can
keep significant
existing jobs in the north of england we
can also enable
other sectors to become part of that so
for example the carbon capture and
storage infrastructure
that would be needed or that would put
in place in the humber would be a great
um partner for
a hydrogen infrastructure so actually
the best one of the best ways to create
hydrogen is by capturing the co2
and when you make it so it's a great
partner for other new technologies and
again
that would make the uk a world leader um
in the next generation of green
technologies that will enable
the whole recovery from c19 and position
as well for a net zero world
thank you so much well uh going to move
to andrew griffith who's a conservative
member of parliament and
former chief business advisor to boris
johnson over new imager
thank you kate and uh and thank you for
inviting me to join this panel because
this
is such an exciting and important topic
um you know if you think about what
we're trying to do it's incredibly
disruptive
you know we've built an economy based on
carbon since we first warmed ourselves
as we crawled out of
the swamp and grabbed a piece of coal on
the seashore
to keep ourselves warm at night and the
ambitious and disruptive goal we set
ourselves as politicians
is over a short number of decades to
completely transform
the economy to completely transform
every aspect of human life
and i'm very excited about that i think
this is going to spawn
multiple new industries
trillions of dollars of potential
revenue new jobs
new employment the sort of employment
that's likely to be outside the center
of our great cities
which is where our economy is too
fixated and too centered at the moment
and the uk has taken a lead i mean you'd
never hear
it from the narrative uh that we hear
about the
environmental lobby but the uk is far
and away the leader
in its ambition and in many of the
aspects of this new economy that we're
going to build
and so my point is look it's wonderful
that we've got people like will here
and the organizations like drax private
sector organizations that can mobilize
innovation and capital are putting their
wheel their shoulder to the wheel
because if we're going to have the sort
of recovery that we need to have
we need to attract trillions of new
investment
and as we know that can't all come on
from the government balance sheet the
government has a role to play
we should set a clear regulatory agenda
and actually i do think this is a space
in which there is more clarity
about the destination and the journey
there than there are
in some other areas we've got to foster
a climate in which people like will and
his contemporaries
feel confident that they can invest and
these are long-term
bets that people are placing the outsize
opportunity
is extremely attractive but we've got to
make sure that the climate is conducive
for that
in the uk as we see at the moment life
is not easy
for businesses but the challenges are
about
certainty and confidence they're not for
once
they're not about the access to capital
uh or the price of that capital
so i think any one of the opportunities
we talked about will's involved in the
generation
business there's the whole mobility
sector
and i'm excited as well as electricity
if i can say
i think there's a great opportunity
potentially in hydrogen
and one of the roles of government
shouldn't be to pick individual winners
but again to be solutions driven
if we've got a clear objective about
where we want to be
we can afford actually to encourage and
foster some innovation
to support some failure along the way in
the hope that by doing so by taking
those risks
we maximize the outsize opportunity to
create jobs and prosperity and wealth
because as you know katie goodness knows
we're going to need it
and so that's what another reason why
this is so important
lots of optimism from you andrew
something something refreshing really
these days uh
we don't get a lot of this is disruptive
this is what this is actually what we're
good at
i mean this was the country that led the
industrial revolution
uh that conquered the oceans because we
were one of the first to master
shipbuilding
and so i definitely see this as an
opportunity through that lens it's not
that it's not going to be easy
and it's not that others aren't going to
see precisely the same opportunity
which is why we've really got to line
ourselves up in a very good way
and go after this well emma pinchbeck uh
chief executive of
energy uk uh do you echo that optimism
actually andrew's really really
helpfully teed me up because the first
thing i was going to say is
anyone in the audience thinking that
this is an environmental revolution
should
rapidly wrap their brains around the
fact it's an industrial one
and and the shift we're likely to see is
a bit like the move to
you know the agrarian age with the
invention the plow and then again the
steam age of the invention the steam
engine
this is the it's a huge technological
shift
and the only difference between this and
previous economic shifts
is that we're having to do it in the age
of the anthropocene where we where we
are aware that there are natural limits
that that are on their own timetable
regardless of how quickly we can get
technology to scale
and that's the fundamental challenge for
governance and for policy
and indeed businesses is making this
industrial revolution happen at the pace
required to meet the environmental
challenges that are very clear to us now
and but luckily unlike you know 10 years
ago when i
started working in energy and in the
environment
we have done it and we know that by
investing in low carbon technology
there's massive economic playback
and people have mentioned offshore wind
in the uk but let's just pick that
because it's the
example probably best known to the
audience where there was a partnership
between
industry and government government help
finance and early stage technology
where we i could identify that there was
massive potential for it in the uk
got it to scale and um
you know years earlier than planned the
technology is now competing fossil fuels
so everywhere you go in the world
you will find a renewables technology
which is now cheaper than the fossil
fuel equivalent
including the additional cost of running
this other systems because they generate
slightly differently like this
rather than like this and including um
everything everything about the upfront
needs
for investment right the way through to
where they are in the system so they are
hugely
hugely
cheap so that's that's the payback
immediately we have most of the
technologies we need actually i agree
that there are some that we need to get
to scale but we know what they are
and and the last thing and the thing i
want to kind of
really emphasize here is we've become
very aware of their co-benefits beyond
the um the provision of low-carbon
services so clean
electrons and molecules so for offshore
wind 90
of the government's investment went to
areas outside the southeast of england
johnny talked about you know the coastal
communities around the uk that have
benefited from these technologies
because fundamentally in a distributed
decentralized decarbonized energy system
assets and investment go all around the
uk and we're aware of the health
benefits because we're much more
conscious of things like air quality
there have been demonstrator projects
where we've used health commissioning
budgets to fund
upgrades to people's homes or upgrades
to boilers because the local health
service literally saves money from doing
that by improving the housing stock
because they get fewer people in with
respiratory illnesses like
because we've started to do this we are
aware
that it is very good value for money for
government to do it
um but there are a few things i think we
need to fix in order to kind of really
push
decarbonization to other areas of the
economy and to keep actually
to maximize those economic benefits to
the uk the first is about the value of
things
everything about kind of the co-benefits
industrial health
social of doing this a very difficult
capture in the way that we currently
evaluate policy so some kind of net zero
test across the entire economy has been
voted something like that would be good
taking another look at the treasury's
green book and how we capture value
would be good
so something about do we fully
understand the benefit of doing this to
the economy
do we have it do we have a an economic
assessment model that's fit for this
revolution
is a huge question the second thing is
to sort the market design out
we're putting new technologies which are
fundamentally different
into the system and we are not changing
the market mechanisms around those at
all so we can't fully capture their
value
if you're drafts and you're offering
flexible energy services you can't tap
into the flexible energy markets fully
to get the benefit of that because
they don't exist and if you're a
customer you certainly can't so if
you're someone with an electric vehicle
plugged into the system you're not going
to see the full value of charging it at
different times or using it like a
battery
because we we don't have the right
market design for it we also don't have
a decent carbon price
um to reflect the cost of co2 in the
economy
and we can't free up investment because
um
our investors can't access the full
value of the assets we're putting in the
system to sort the markets out
the third thing is to properly invest in
the infrastructure we need whether
that's networks or new technology like
ccos
and to really realize the value of the
industrial stuff so our competitors
around the world
alongside investing in the technology
markets do things like investing keys
q-u-a-y so that they can get big boats
to build big wind turbines
easily into their ports and we do not do
that kind of investment well in the uk
and i'd argue we need to
um and relatedly we need to invest in
skills and training people up for this
revolution for the future
you want to be putting boilers into
people's homes
hydrogen boilers possibly or better yet
heat pumps you need our heating
engineers to know how to do that
and lastly and very quickly as a
personal bug bear of mine
we're going into people's homes next
we're doing transport systems
we are going to be changing things that
are very personal and visible in
people's communities and which have
massive impacts and benefits for them in
their lives
and we do such a terrible job of telling
them that
so the government is very pro the smart
meter roll out we're putting this
technology into people's homes
um and i haven't heard one government
minister talk about having a smart meter
installed in their house and the
difference that would make to then being
able to do that in everyone else's homes
would be
massive and it's so underestimated when
we're talking about this big economic
shift so i'd
put a punt in for some more time or
money
being invested in how we talk about this
revolution not just how we execute it
thank you so much emma there's clearly
so much to dig into we already have some
questions coming in
please remember if you'd like to submit
a question to our panel you can do so
through spectator tv that will come
straight to me and i will put it to them
but i'm going to use my position in this
chair a little while longer just to ask
a few questions
um well i wanted to pick up on something
that andrew spoke about um
and and the role of private companies uh
in
in the green revolution the committee on
climate change estimates that the total
cost of getting to net zero will be
roughly
50 billion pounds per year an estimate
from the treasury in the department of
business energy and international
strategy a while back put the figure at
70 billion pounds
per year or a trillion by 2050 and
many would say that it's worth the cost
but you still have to find the money and
arguably that can't all come from the
taxpayer some of it
is going to have to come much of it's
going to have to come from
private companies do you think the
balance is right so far
and what role do you think companies
like drax and others are going to play
in this revolution
no thanks so i think that there's a
couple of um if we look backwards
there's a couple of very good examples
of the way the government has done
um a great job and incentivizing next
generation technologies i mean the
offshore wind one is a great one right
when the first cfds for offshore wind
were 150 pounds a megawatt hour
you know probably tripled the price of
power at the time and now as emma
pointed out
you know offshore wind is cheaper than
you know the next best source of the
next cheapest source of power pretty
much
everywhere across the uk and in most
countries and so
that to me is a a classic example of how
government intervention
in a sort of a market that needed
support needed confidence has worked
super well right
you say i think the same idea worked for
carbon capture and storage right so two
things i think the government can do one
is
for what we want to do which is negative
emissions you know we need
we need a market whereby effectively
that we can get long-term certainty
in a price of carbon right so actually
when we actually
reduce carbon we can get compensated for
that right if you look at the forecast
from bays for example they're looking at
a price of carbon that could be as high
as 100 pounds a ton by the end of the
20s right
we can do this for that price right so
if you tell me now
we'll give you certainty in that price
for the long term and if
if the price goes higher happy to share
that benefit back if it's prices under
that we need that sort of government
support so there's
that government sort of government can
provide certainty we can we will invest
right then we will put you know
billions if not more into this to make
that all happen right the second thing
the government can do is they can put
the infrastructure in place right
and this is what i think is a really
interesting example of how
infrastructure
can enable competition in new industry
so if you put the infrastructure through
the humber to do carbon capture and
storage
and then you say to industry there you
can have access to that infrastructure
but you need to compete so we'll you
know we'll allow the people that put in
the lowest cost bid for decarbonization
have access to that the government puts
the framework they put the
infrastructure and then
the industry effectively will put the
capital to put the projects in place to
make it happen i think that all the all
and
the exciting thing for me about this is
all the pieces are in place right all
the
things that we need for next generation
carbon capture or for effects and
negative emissions
are part of the tool the the toolkit the
government has already used right
jonathan what do you make of that
offshore wind is often held up as
a very good example of where things went
right it's proven to be much more
successful
than was originally estimated and
cheaper as well should we be so
optimistic to think that will be true
for
for all future forms of energy whether
it be carbon capture nuclear
is is the story of offshore wind bound
to repeat itself are we going to
struggle a bit more along the way
it's definitely not not bound to repeat
itself but you can give it a good chance
of doing so
um as well said that one of the reasons
why behind uk offshore insects are being
so
successful was really good policy
underpinning it
and you know the cfd is a comfortable
difference that you know basically
guarantees a price for the amount
for energy produced has been a major
factor in
costs falling and has been copied by
other countries around the world there's
a great piece of policymaking
so there's no reason why you know
without well
no reason why unless you put like proper
thoughts and proper rationale behind
devising these policies why you can't
create
real good real frameworks that other
technologies can really thrive in
and then be as successful as offshore
wind
andrew how much can companies plan and
have certainty and we all know that
certainty is key
when we haven't heard from government
yet what its pathway is to achieving
that zero by 2050.
the energy white paper has been delayed
many of its plans around
it it's green energy path have been
delayed
understandably so i don't think anybody
questions in the year 2020 why we have
had those delays
but still um you know every day we get
closer to that target and we have really
yet to hear
from government how it's going to
achieve um this target that it's it's
put into law so
what do you think we can expect when we
finally get the announcements
i i don't know any more than anyone else
i'm not a member of the government
um about when we expect that um if
if i was looking i think there's a huge
wave i know because i speak speak to
people in the community
a huge wave of international capital
that's looking
to be deployed both into space and in
the uk
and i suspect probably um as we go
through the end of this year and start
looking into 2021
which is going to be a banner year for
the uk
that that's the time that people want to
move off the sidelines
and start placing i said bets i don't
mean bets but
but start putting money to uh to work
behind some of these projects
so if you ask me when would be a perfect
time and i think this will be the case
um the government to come forward
between now and the end of this calendar
year
that would enable us to go into 2021
with cop 26
uh leadership of the g7 hopefully coming
out the back end of this
pandemic obviously completing things
like the spending review
all of those could come together in a
really strong sweet spot
um and that would be what i would hope
that that would be what i would hope we
may get some um some threading of some
of the policy areas between now and then
if i if i can just follow up will's and
johnny's comments as well
i mean one of the huge opportunities it
seems to me
is the uk's capital markets i mean
carbon is going to be a tradable
commodity it's possibly
going to be the complete tradable
commodity
of the 21st and 22nd centuries um and
one of the things that
our capital markets have always been
exceptionally good at
is trading and pricing and creating
markets and legal frameworks
and sometimes insurance frameworks in
all of these markets you think about
you know the the gold market was traded
out of london
for almost all of its life now you know
with the exception of a few esoteric
parts of the united kingdom without
wishing to
uh offend anybody we've never been major
in terms of the production of gold
but huge swathes of of the world's gold
was traded through london
and the same is through of many
commodities so one of the
contributions that we're going to make
to this global revolution i hope
is to create the facility of very deep
very liquid
very expertised capital markets as well
um do you agree with andrew's bullish
timeline that
between now and the end of the year
would be the time to make some of these
announcements
of course the chancellor postponed his
budget not feeling
like it was the time or the appropriate
time to make
some pretty hefty economic decisions but
perhaps there is an argument that
uh much what we already knew about what
has to be done on green energy was
before the cova crisis so at least
something could be
put forward before the end of the there
is
year
better time for this um for for three
different reasons the first and the kind
of most predictably hippie-ish stories
is that we are rapidly running out of
time to
to do the to do it with the least bad
consequences for the way
that we all live that's that's why
people talk about 1.5 or 2 degrees i
mean
just to kind of labor the economic point
bits of california have been on fire for
much of the year and they're the
fifth largest economy in the world there
are huge impacts to this you know one
the difference between 1.5 and 2 degrees
represents a fairly significant amount
in terms of
um functioning global economies and our
global supply chains and parts of the
world becoming habitable or not
and i think we always forget that that
there's a kind of economic
reason that we're pushing for the
environmental timetable we are
so there's that on their politics there
are so many good opportunities to do
this
with this with this government at this
time um
and i'd say especially because of the
pandemic which is that
you know we've we've heard the
government make a case for investment
for
a sustainable future growth and we know
now
from having done this with several other
areas of the economy that an investment
in decarbonisation for heat
or transport or pushing on with past
extra carbonization is likely to
to return tenfold in terms of jobs and
money back to the uk
um and there are lots of policy
opportunities to do it so
you know you mentioned the budget of
course and and hopefully eventually
we'll see something from the treasury
but
the energy white paper is due the
government will have to
give its ndc for the negotiations next
year it's kind of our own
road map to dealing with the paris
agreement that's due in december we've
got the sixth carbon budget in december
there are lots and lots of opportunities
to say things at the scale required
and on the point about carbon pricing i
agree and i would say
just to be a bit punchy that
we have the technologies that we need
we've we've had the advice from the
committee on climate change from the
industry
from experts for about a decade now
about what needs to be done and the only
thing that changes is the imperative
and and our kind of knowledge about the
benefits back
um we understand it will be a public
private partnership we literally just
need the action from the government the
only thing that is slow now in this
transition
is is is policy you know that the
markets
are going um and
that i think any of the above would do
you know a whole economy carbon price if
you want to go for a pure markets
approach
would be better than what we've got now
an interventionist policy approach that
regulates heat
would be would help kick-start the
economy you know
um offering certainty for investors by
continuing mechanisms that just
stabilize the investment climate like
the cfd
you know there are we have all the
answers to this stuff the frustration of
industry is often that we're just
waiting
and and the time is really now for
government to do something about it and
that is with the
um that is with a
a career of being largely optimistic
about what government can do
and feeling as someone said that this
government has already done more
for green stuff in the last six months
and we've then we've seen in the last
sort of five ten years
so um it's not meant to sound like sour
grapes it's meant to sound like an
industry that really wants to get
cracking
just waiting for for the right policy
mechanisms to do it
well you've made the case for bioenergy
carbon capture and
storage uh there's a lot of talk of new
technology being necessary to hit the
2015 net zero target um but i think
viewers would be interested to know from
your perspective has that
all the technology been developed that
can get us to net zero
or are we still relying in theory on
some more developments that don't quite
exist yet
very good question katie let me let me
um talk a little bit about
greenhouse gas removal technologies in
general right so the idea is
the general idea is can we take co2 out
of the atmosphere
bury it under the ground and stick it
back sort of into the rocks
where it belongs one technology that
people are
more familiar with is so-called direct
air capture where literally you're
running
the air through a set of screens with
giant fans and effectively that
the idea is it goes through a membrane
which can separate out the co2 and let
the rest of the air go through
right and that does work there are
operating plants that do that but it is
quite expensive right it costs about 300
pounds
a ton right but again to your point
technology is there right
now bex which is effectively bioenergy
as i said bioenergy plus carbon capture
and storage all of the pieces are there
today right so we
generate power we generate about five
percent of the uk's power every year
using biomass at the power station in
yorkshire so that's the first step in
the process
well proven we've been doing it for you
know five ten years
already and we basically have you know
gone from
emitting about 20 million tons of co2 to
effectively now
close to zero not very much carbon
capture and storage which is the next
step in the process to complete the
whole chain
is being done today right so for the
technology that we would want to use
is in place for example in the u.s at a
plant called petranova doing
a million tons of carbon capture per
year
we're and that's that's technology
effectively this uh
delivered by mitsubishi heavy industries
we have a trial project or a pilot
project that started up last week
we captured our first ton of co2 with
them already so that's technology is
now we're basically figuring out how we
will scale that at the drax power
station
and we think we can be ready to make a
full-blown investment decision by 2023
as long as the government framework is
in place and the infrastructure is in
place as i mentioned before so all the
pieces are there
let me i wanted to while i have the
chance follow up on andrew's comment
about markets which i am a big fan of as
well and if you think about
seed carbon markets right now there's
lots of people who have a demand for
for those carbon credits right so people
who are meeting co2 they need the
credits to offset what they admit right
there are not very many companies who
actually are have the potential to
create credits effectively to
provide a supply of credits right people
who are capturing co2
and removing it from the atmosphere see
what the economics of that you know lots
of demand prices go up lots of supply
prices go down right so
fundamentally if we can actually deliver
more greenhouse gas removal technologies
create a market where those buyers and
sellers we can help bring the cost of
decolonization down i think that's a key
part
of our argument
sorry jonathan do you agree that the
technology is there
uh to to meet the 2050 goals and that
we're not relying on anything that has
yet to be concocted out of thin air and
also to this point about markets that
that will and emma have mentioned now
and emma said markets are ready for
these changes they're
actually quite excited about them is is
that true across the board or is that
just true for the big players
are the small to medium-sized players
perhaps not so ready for this radical
change
um so in terms of the technology being
ready um everything that we need to get
to our net zero target is is in place
but saying that there's no harm in
taking a punt on something that might
come along and make things easier along
the way
so you know we know um we know how to
decarbonize the power system for example
we know how to build
um renewables we know how to build
nuclear power stations but
you know a few uh target investment in
bioenergy and carbon capture isn't isn't
a bad thing it's not going to slow
anything down
same with decarbonizing our homes we
know that heat pumps work we know
how to install them and how to use them
but again you know
taking a taking a chance on hydrogen
boilers for example hybrid boilers that
combine
both might help further down the line so
while there's arguments for using what
we have there's
you know investment and research should
continue into
technologies that you know could could
come and you know sort of
not save the day but definitely help um
you wouldn't have example thought five
years ago
that offshore wind would be the the
backbone of the uk's power system you'd
have thought it would be if it was going
to be renewables it would be onshore
wind and solar
but it was um you know it was through
targeted support and backing an industry
where you've seen something that really
really developed
and on the point about markets um
there's there's no shortage in in people
calling for this just to look at the
power sector um
you know there's no there's currently a
whole host of services provided by
big and small players in the power
sector which aren't um aren't reimbursed
properly
so this year national upgrade has had a
lot of issues we're not issued a
learning curve in balancing the grid
while we've had lower demand due to
factories in places that weren't being
closed and a higher proportion of energy
coming from
renewables which have a variable output
as emma said and
you know it managed to come up with
services to sort of you know create
virtual power stations out of car
batteries for example or to incentivize
people to turn on their washing machine
later at night for example these these
are opportunities that can be open to
anyone from
you know a household with a fridge to um
some big industrial players that have
you know huge loads on the grid
the is getting this framework right and
getting this these opportunities open to
everyone
and through their energy suppliers or
through government policies that
companies don't
interact with directly which can really
spur things on
andrew we've had a question in um
more or less asking uh if the government
and and the conservative party are so
committed to the
net zero target why not entertain a
green new deal
uh what why not uh bring in a a
high-paying green jobs
program uh encouraged indeed mandated by
government policies
some on the left particularly in america
that the democratic party
have been advocating for i mean what's
the line really between government
involvement and
your opinion going a step too far
i mean i think that can be quite
semantic in truth i mean everyone's got
their own little program of
of green initiatives and this government
is making very substantial commitments
of taxpayers money to things like the
green homes grant which is a great
program and and it's getting going
uh it's obviously got a long way to run
um sometimes
the the the things that hold us back the
inhibitions that
are not just you know the competitive
bidding war for how much
of the taxpayers resources the state can
spend but there's of course a role for
that the the state is a big actor in
every market
um often its role as a procurer itself
can be a real boon to market so that can
be a
a great progressive way of allowing
businesses
sometimes small businesses which i'm a
huge fan of because they're often the
most innovative
that can be a way of small businesses
getting to scale
and in turn attracting and mobilizing
capital themselves so
i mean personally i would hope the
government doesn't just decide
that its biggest intervention in
achieving this incredibly
important trans transformation is
getting into a bidding contest about how
much state money it can spend
because mostly because i don't think
that will get us to where we need to get
to
i do think you know some of these are
global
we need to mobilize the power of
innovation
and you can do that you can see in the
um in the crisis we've just had
um it's been an incredibly difficult
period for lots of different
organizations
but i would argue actually the private
sector has done a pretty good job
i mean we have one or two moments but
then the food supply chains that are
entirely in private sector hands
have just got on and solve the problem
which is what
risk capital does each and every day and
i'm much more excited perhaps
from a natural philosophical perspective
about being able to create markets
to shape markets yes certainly i take
emma's challenge about
you know getting on and doing some of
this stuff completely agree with that
but that to me is the more exciting side
of the equation
you know two politicians just bidding
about bidding
to spend other people's money without
thinking more holistically
i think is less exciting and we
shouldn't forget as part of this
that we've got to bring the consumers
with us as well now i think in some
cases
they're there or they're even dragging
dragging government a little bit further
forward
but there are some other areas where
consumers aren't there
and that's where you need political
leadership as well i think because
you know there are challenges and
challenges mean there are some
trade-offs as well
it's important the economy is in good
shape because if you're going to take
people on a journey to make some of
those difficult trade-offs and decisions
it's clearly as helpful uh that as many
household
economics are in as good shape as
possible and that we can minimize
the scarring effect of the covid crisis
which i think the government has done
a pretty good job on overall emma we
have
multiple viewers today writing in to ask
about different kinds of
energy and technology somebody said
what's happened to combine heat and
power
you heard a lot of that talk back in the
90s but now it seems to be
old news another has said a question
from pete what about many nuclear plants
as envisioned by rolls-royce
as a power source i mean there almost
seem to be countless numbers
of new forms of energy that our viewers
will be hearing a lot about how does one
go about
um determining you know which
is best which is most efficient which is
cheapest i mean is there just a go-to
for consumers
to learn more about these kinds of
energy and to decide which one they
think they like to back or support or
get behind
yeah firstly um come at me on twitter
because i could literally do that all
day as a conversation but they're um
and and it's the job of energy uk to
represent the kind of entire energy
industry right so
um uh if you want to act me on twitter
for personal views
but what i'm about to say reflects the
the kind of industry view of things too
and actually addresses some of the stuff
that we've been talking about right and
some of your questions this is the truth
of it
there's no point in an ideological
purity test on this stuff either side of
the island and i said this at
labour party conference last week it it
it naturally because it's a whole
economic shift will require
some interventionist stuff um in areas
of the economy which are hard to shift
or where just incentives won't cut it
and there's some stuff where government
can get out of the way
and not touch it and um you know on the
on the left you hear a conversation
about wanting to say nationalize
offshore wind when and i always used to
go
why when it's working um and on on the
right you hear
not wanting to intervene or spend
government money on some things or being
reluctant to kind of tell
people what to do in their own homes
even when we can see that there'll be a
massive economic payback from doing it
and instead just looking at say carbon
pricing and the answer is it's going to
be a blended solution of both and on the
technology side of things
um the straightforward answer is the
stuff that has been successful has been
able to compete in the market as it's
currently designed
um and so at the point in the transition
where we're at now
it's pretty clear which the big winners
will be
and we've mentioned renewables and
pretty much the entire energy industry
our investors
and our markets are reorientating
themselves around the idea that the
incumbent
will be variable renewable technology
and plus stuff that works with it now in
the uk
that said in the uk we can only do about
70 renewables
maybe 80 renewables before there are
some technical barriers and hurdles that
we
worry about and don't have the answers
to yet and so
we know we're going to need some kind of
other technology nuclear
um bex uh hydrogen with ccus on some
other thing
in the mix and that's the point about we
need to invest for that technology too
um with the rest of the economy
it's still up for grabs so again because
of what we're doing on the power sector
you can see
more or less what's going to happen in
other areas of the economy we're going
to need lots of heat pumps
some hydrogen boilers we're going to
need um mostly electric vehicles perhaps
some hydrogen and freight we're going to
need
something for aviation and shipping
which is likely to be a biofuel or
hydrogen and we're going to need some
negative emissions technologies
and it's pretty straightforward and the
reason some stuff we don't talk about
or has gone out of fashion or anything
else is because they've either lost in
the competitive market or we
can see how the whole system is going to
work together um
i really echo what johnny and others
have said
we need to do what we know that we're
good at
even and especially when it's boring
like energy efficiency
we need to invest for the technologies
of the future because we're hoping to be
able to provide global leadership to
export to keep the industrial benefits
in the uk
and i and above all for this
conversation i think we really do need
to sort our markets out and johnny
mentioned this ability for people to
really properly capture the value in our
energy markets of these new technologies
and what they do
we've talked about carbon pricing we've
talked about setting certainty
for investors this is all about just
making it easier to pull the money in
that we think is there
and to maximize the benefits back to the
uk of doing it
and i know i've ranted so i'll just
finish on this i used to hear all the
time
from government about why we didn't
manufacture
even more on children technology in the
uk than we already do or even more
offshore wind components in the uk than
we already do you know we have factories
in the uk
but they came as a second wave and when
we first did offshore when we were
importing a lot of the components and
the genuine reason for that is
government hesitated about whether to
invest in wind
when it was very early stage at the
stage that bex
is now or hydrogen is now or what heat
electrification is now we we blinked
and scandinavia invested instead now we
have the cheapest
um energy source in the world in
offshore wind and a globally leading
market but if we'd invested early we'd
have also had more of the plant
the manufacturing and the jobs here now
that's catching up
but if you want it from the very
beginning and you want to be the world
champion the technology you have to be
brave and invest immediately
as soon as you can see the potential and
and everyone in this conversation
has listed like 15 different
technologies where that is true
uh a viewer named grace writes in to ask
the panel what your
take is on extinction rebellion and
whether or not our panel is
sympathetic to their aims and objectives
and
i suppose will this kind of gets to the
crux of it about swaying hearts and
minds because you can bring in all the
technology
and all the structures but you have to
get people on board too
what do you think is the best way to
sway hearts and minds
well that's a very good question and one
that i find um frankly attracts is often
quite
frustrating because i think as all of
you probably know um drax there are many
people who
don't really agree with what tracks is
doing we spend a lot of time
trying to make it clear that what we do
for example that supports forest is very
is helpful to forestry as opposed to the
reverse um that what we're trying to do
is to
reduce carbon emissions not the reverse
so there's a lot of things that we're
trying to do that are
quite positive and but ultimately i
think there's there's sort of two
answers to this question one is that
the um you know there are specific sort
of
we need to make the facts clear right i
mean there is there are fact-based
arguments and we need to make those
arguments around you know what we do
about what others do
about what risks are um so one of the
things for example i think is really
important as we
move into a world of carbon capture and
storage is make clear
that that's been done before that it is
safe and we're sort of clear on that and
and in a sense engage with people to
make sure they understand it and not
sort of dismiss their concerns because
there are real issues now we need to
make sure that we are
um aware of those the other the other
part of it is that's that's the minds
piece so the other way is we have to
engage with people on
an emotional level too right i mean we
are we're trying to do the right thing
we're
trying to solve this problem i thought
it was um
interesting when andrew suggested that i
that me and my contemporaries need to be
convinced to invest i think it's
probably
as important that other generations are
excited about this too and we need to
win that we need to win those hearts uh
as well so
uh it's really about the hearts and
minds kind of battle yeah
jonathan do you think um ideology uh in
both directions whether you're
extinguishing rebellion on one end or
more skeptical of climate change on the
other end do you think that extreme
ideology is getting in the way
of of moving towards net zero
um i don't think it's helping helping
things um so for a long time we
we only had widespread publication of
extreme ideology on one side
and now with extinction rebellion um
with their sort of second year of action
you're seeing that on the other side
and what needs to be balanced is you
know extinction rebellion done a great
job of
raising awareness of climate change in
the uk of you know putting forward some
some solutions which some say are too
too fast some say to you know to
appending of the world depending of the
economy
um but they've also become very
polarizing and now there's a big
trade-off to do between
what is an acceptable level of raising
awareness and pushing these viewpoints
um and then how does you know turning
turning people off and
turning people against you undermine
that to some degree so
while they certainly have have you know
their further first year of action did
tied in with other things that tired and
with the school strikes it tied in with
the david attribute program on the bbc
both of which
um with it with the extinction rebellion
protests definitely brought climate
change to the top of the news
and some things they've done this year
have possibly undermined some of that by
being slightly too polarizing
andrew you mentioned that um if you were
if you were
calling the shots at the very top you
would speed things up in terms of
launching the the real green agenda to
get this to net zero
presumptive kate you'll get me into all
sorts of trouble that was not what i
said
but but there we go okay outline the
opportunity
you did i'm sorry i thought that was a
fair summary you're right you did
outline the opportunity and a good one
at that
um but uh you know even for those out
there who would like to see things move
slightly faster to grasp that
opportunity
do you think some of the tactics that
have been used to raise awareness about
climate change
over the past few years have been a step
too far
look up i i think the good news is in a
way we've moved beyond that
i mean you you know when every parish
council
every district virtually every public
organization
has declared a climate emergency the
good news in a way is i think we can
avoid some of the polarizing parts of
the debate and start putting our
problem-solving hats on
you know that's the bit that excites me
to be honest that's the
intersection between government policy
um
all of us as a role with roles of
communicators
um but also harnessing you know my
hinterland
the the power of business to do good um
so if we can make that work if we can
stay aligned
stay with the journey bring people with
us expand the base of people
um i think we've got all the ingredients
for success this has been a
very positive and uplifting call so i
don't think we need to actually go back
to closing down newspapers as if as if
this is something that that anybody's
really in the mainstream of opinion
not already applying enough energy to um
so that that's that's like let's just
move forward let's move forward together
but positively and constructively i
i must say i do wish every conversation
about
net zero and climate change uh had the
the structure and the intellect that has
been displayed on
uh today's panel um emma are we at risk
however was it you know it does seem
everybody wants to hit this target
everybody wants to invest and and get to
net zero are we at risk of being
slightly
dishonest one of our viewers says how do
we ensure that we're not just offshoring
heavy industry
and there has been a lot of criticism
even around something like the
paris climate accord that actually if
you really dug into it
a lot of developed countries are patting
themselves on the back for
shipping off their carbon emissions
elsewhere when we talk about net zero
do we really mean net zero or or do we
mean actually
shipping off some heavy industry i'm
gonna like formally take off my energy
uk hat
and put on my i used to be head of the
climate change program at wwf hat
so i um have done some work on
international climate change and
and on and on carbon budgets and how
they work and don't look
they're imperfect but they're what we've
got and they're particularly what we've
got on a ticking clock and this is
this is kind of to your point on the
extinct rebounding question as well and
what they're asking for
in the scale of it versus the time
allowed and for me it's always been
it's always been more sensible to work
with the world as it is and try to get
it to change rapidly rather than
deconstruct it and do
and and do it better as we build it um
try and make it go better but i don't
think we've got the time to really
mess about with with extreme ends of
anything
and and on the way that we structure
international
climate change agreements they're
imperfect because of often diplomatic
realities so
we only account for our territorial
emissions in the uk and globally because
that's how we report right up to the un
and the reason for that is if we
don't do that and you start looking at
your consumption footprint which
we should kind of come on to that in a
minute but if you start accounting your
consumption footprint as your national
responsibility
pretty quickly you can see in a
globalized world how you might end up
telling india what to do with its
factories
or bangladesh where we import a lot of
our goods from so for reasons of
national sovereignty we do our
accounting territorially
we do however publish our consumption
data and the uk government has said that
it will start to look at it
so that's interesting on the consumption
point
i think and it comes back to cons the
difference between 1.5 and 2 degrees
roughly comes down to individual
lifestyle choices
it comes and to consumption and to doing
less not just better
and i spent a career arguing that we can
do this if we just do things better but
the truth is we also need to do
fewer things probably and um that means
flying less
and for people who fly a lot bearing our
diets for people that eat a lot of meat
just doing
doing things so that other people can do
them too it's a really hard conversation
to have with the public
but what the climate assembly showed um
is that actually the public have got
quite a strong
attitude for having some action on
individual consumption choices the
measures the climate assembly came back
with were
frequent flyer levees and banning suvs
so this is like a
really broad demographic of the country
that they they talk to as part of that
process so i thought that was really
interesting and we do need to figure out
how we have that conversation too
um what i would say though on on the
point about
you know is this enough
most of this is about system change
however you view it
market change or or you know policy
change at the extreme ends it's all it's
all about change and a lot of that is in
the hands of government and industry
where the big leaders are
and we have seen that if we get
investment
right if we get the framework right if
we get policy right the change happens
far far
far quicker than we expected and so my
thing these days is
can we stop having the ideological row
about the right
process overall the right long-term
target date the
right overall technology and just crack
on with what we have been told
that we have to do right now the
technologies we have available
right now the very very relatively easy
stuff
that we could just do tomorrow because
if we get that right it's likely to go
faster than we think and as we do that
i think everything else becomes possible
and we might surprise ourselves
well we only have a few minutes left so
i'm going to
ask the panel the same question and
please keep your answers short just so
we can squeeze it all in
um well i'll start with you but the
question i want to ask is
we spend a lot of time looking towards
2050 now
it is the date in everyone's diary as to
when we need to
achieve our net zero target but i'd like
to hear from
you what you think success would look
like by 2025
what can we achieve in the next few
years that genuinely gets on the path to
a greener planet
i will be very specific i mean the uk
government can
enable and have in place carbon capture
and storage infrastructure and people
capturing in storage delivering both
carbon reduction and negative emissions
by 2025 that's absolutely
in the sort of legislative time frame or
that the regulatory time frame the
government is currently working on if
they do that that'll be a huge step
forward
thanks jonathan um so a lot of the stuff
in 2025 the decisions are due to be made
as soon as possible um
so running through a few so with
building the heat and building strategy
is due
imminently hopefully by the end of the
year by 2025 we
hope to see action on gas boilers not
being installed in people's houses for
example or
more ambitious efficiency target for the
power sector we need to know
you know what we're going to do when all
our nuclear power stations close what
we're going to do when the early wind
farms and solar
solar farms start to close uh need
long-term certainty there there's an
industrial decarbonization strategy
during the first few months of next year
that should give long-term certainty for
industry what what it should look like
over the next few years
investment decisions start to be made
and by 2025 stuff is being built
and then finally for electric vehicles
once we have a a phase-out date
you know enshrined in law then we'll
start to see more and more of them on
the road we'll see the infrastructure
going around it and we'll see all the
benefits that come out of that
jonathan very quickly that's a very
comprehensive list
do you think that's all achievable by
2025 i mean on a scale from one to ten
how optimistic are you being
i'd say it's all very achievable yeah in
fact this should be you know that's
probably quite
quite reserved really could go a lot
further a lot quicker
all right then andrew i mean i'd like to
see
hundreds of thousands of green jobs uh
incremental green jobs uh and jobs where
people
can tie their own prosperity and that of
their family
to the progress that we're making
decarbonizing the economy
um and that's important because it means
we're successfully growing industries
which in turn
can become exporters which in turn can
allow us to achieve the prosperity we
need as a nation
and it's important because it means that
we can close that circle
where you do as you start to make some
of the choices
uh that came out of the um the citizens
parliament and that emma talked about
where people can actually see that
virtuous cycle whereby
as we go on this journey as we make some
of the potential i don't say sacrifices
but some of the changes
in our own lives they can also see that
we're building prosperity and jobs for
the next generation you know capitalism
in its simplest sense needs that the
deployment of capital
to create shared prosperity for us all
and so
we've got to put this if we're serious
about putting this at the heart
of a green growth recovery and leveling
up as we started to uh to talk about the
beginning
then we're going to need people up and
down this country and ideally a little
bit more up than down if we're truthful
um tying their own fortunes and success
to the green economy and i
like others absolutely think we can do
that by 2025.
just a very quick follow-up on that
andrew one person has written in asking
if we should prioritize
cities over more rural areas just for
the immediate
uh public health benefit in terms of air
quality
and the rest we know that city centers
are on their knees at the moment because
of the covet 19 crisis as people haven't
been going to the office a lot of
service-based industry
is is struggling to stay afloat do you
see
these two issues combining in some way
to actually
create more jobs in the future that can
also tackle this issue of city pollution
absolutely and i don't think we've
probably got enough time kate today
to go through what we need to do to our
cities because we need to
reinvent our cities and make our cities
green and sustainable
but most of all make them fantastic live
work spaces
and some of our cities most of our
cities aren't that today
and we see right now empty trains
shuttling through the countryside devoid
of people
if you look at some of the reason why
continental european cities have found
it so much easier to persuade people to
return to the workspace
it's because it's a short ride or a
cycle
or a you know a walk um so we've got
we've got a much you know another topic
for another spectator panel on another
day
but how do we revitalize re-imagine uh
the city in a sustainable future
um and it's it's a great opportunity
it's a win-win it's a win for people's
quality of life
for the environment for decarbonizing
and again
within that holds the seeds of our
future prosperity
well thrilled to have you already
committed to another spectator panel
spectator panel andrew that's fantastic
and emma
what is uh what what does a good 2025
look like for you
all right i think this is more or less
the same as johnny's list but let's give
it a go
and government can invest in
infrastructure and network stuff so
things like ev charging or um the
networks whether that's gas or
electricity that we're going to plug all
this technology on
um that's something that they can show
really respond building retrofit dig rds
i feel like we've been asking for that
for years and energy efficiency is
resource cost negative to the economy
we just need to make people's homes
better places for them to live and start
on heat to carbonization
the government can start designing
energy markets that actually reflect the
energy system we have and will
definitely have by 2025
they can allow more competition for
investment they can allow the retailers
to actually make some money so that they
can invest
and we can kind of enable some of these
new services that johnny was talking
about by
allowing people to access markets and do
really clever things
and we can sort our industrial export
policy out so that we can
make sure that the jobs we create in the
uk can be useful as other countries to
carbonize
and we can invest in some of the
infrastructure like
roads for access or or keys for large
boats that we need for the next wave of
renewables development and we can
support
um next generation technologies whether
that's you mentioned smrs earlier but
you know bec
ccs all of the stuff that we have not
got down the cost curve yet that we need
to to do the same thing with as we did
for offshore wind
and lastly to start where i finished we
do not value things properly in the
economy when we're having this
conversation so if you wanted to silver
bullet that overnight would transform
how we think about this stuff
and net zero tests across the entire
economy and across our policy making
would be transformative and and the
carbon price
for how the markets function
well no small tasks that we have to
achieve in the next five years
uh let alone by 2050 but a wonderful
start i think today
on our panel jonathan will andrew and
emma thank you so much for joining me
i'm sorry we can't thank you in the
usual way but i'm sure that our
audiences
at home are applauding uh if you're
watching on from your office or your
home thank you so much for tuning in
much more to come on spectator tv today
for the spectators alternative
conference tomorrow and wednesday as
well so keep tuning in and we'll see you
at the next panel
thank you all